foreign
[Music]
theme is social equality police
brutality
um
Media news propaganda the things that we
unfortunately have to see it feels to me
as a black man day in and day out
[Music]
really weighs on me and bugs me I have
to keep addressing like the same thing
and people think like oh like you live
in your dreams you spoke where I was
traveling the world and stuff it's true
but I I really would like to just write
like love poems if I could but the
reality is like Nina Simone said you
have the artist's duties to reflect the
times I've watched War comments on
colored kids who were the like Acres of
daffodils anchored in bodies of bloody
water where the deceased are greeted
with the Deep indifference
I've witnessed
temperamental white teens being tamed
with tasers but black babies with empty
hands are oftentimes pacifier with
gunfire
I've even seen people pour their phones
from pockets and purses like like
pistols to shoot indisputable proof but
but Facebook footage is never a
footprint for indictment here
the reality is
hands up or not gunshots turn our torsos
into hashtags
therefore we reform at tribute tweets
and attempt to retract that trauma but
that that trick is never a treatment for
our Trail of Tears
especially when especially when
especially when I do feel like we're
making progress but we have a long ways
to go so if something I'm saying strikes
a chord or resonates with a student just
one I feel like my job is done because
that student can go on to change the
course of the world
it's hard to break into this field when
the first thing everyone notices about
you is your race look at my face why
can't I also inhabit this space
there's diversity in the birds and the
trees but we have not figured out how to
guarantee the same diversity in the
kinds of people that want to protect
them we are all looking to do sort of
this broad reaching conception of
thought through sound to be able to
reach the listener and help conjure up
images of the difficulty of living in
this time period but also the hope
that's coupled with it in order to gain
a deeper understanding and empathy you
know these words and the music and all
of these things that we're dealing with
are just a means of trying to
communicate a better way of being with
one another
the harmonies
of all things
resonating
as
one
[Music]
oh
ah
[Applause]
[Music]
look at these centers around the
resilience of black women to imagine
what it's like being born as a black
woman into a world that's you know
pretty unjust to you
[Music]
how we've had to navigate
uh through so many things and really
always emerge
like still hopeful and still
joyful and you know all of the emotions
and all of the
things that just you know go along with
a certain kind of struggle
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
you know
and it's always great to see someone as
vibrant as Fred his conducting style is
is unique is very energetic he's moving
he's he's sort of in the moment picking
different pieces of this and this and
and I think that that's a that's really
important to have someone that is rooted
in the traditions of conducting while
being so experimental
thank you
[Music]
foreign
as possible musically really
um you know it's situations like this
are a really good opportunity to I think
step outside of one's comfort zone
especially when collaborating with
others uh and being given an opportunity
to share your sort of musical voice and
identity uh in a way that adds to
someone else's Vision reimagining this
american made
the way I see it we don't look the part
oh fit the picturesque Europe being
picture frame the same as Mona Lisa see
our Beauty be different
curly be be kinky be cornrows on
cornbread fed figures cut to serve face
Flawless
we dictate the market masterfully
supplying the demand for cultural Trends
appropriated on countless occasions yet
somehow we innovate we innovate we
innovate to no end I feature this spoken
word artist that I think is really able
to put all of the themes that the song
is about in the words and communicate
that in the most powerful poignant way
possible his name's Orlando Watson and
then I'm also featuring Andrew Renfro
one of my best friends guitarists we
went to school together and they're just
integral to getting the message across
[Music]
whose face who's peace peace
as it used to be peace ain't promised
your honor let's be honest and
acknowledge that
it must be now
opportunity